attention we are going to introduce you
to the work of hackers in the real world
so that you could recognize an attack in
time and be able to protect yourself
against it or even better to prevent it
forewarned is forearmed so that the
actions shown in our video cannot be
copied we have hidden some of the
commands the names of the programs are
obscured and key parts of the procedures
are omitted we are not hackers we are
specialists in cyber security
we hope this is an interesting and
useful watch for you
Cyprus the Netherlands Germany the
hacker is on the Move in search of a
victim he's interested in the RJ45
twisted pair it could be in a
residential building or in an office
building the main thing is that the
cable is publicly available and there
are no Witnesses nearby
not here
and that's not it either
but here it's open
the basement
we're going down
yes this is it that's what he needs
today I will tell you and show you how
sniffing with a twisted pair works and
why it can be dangerous
sniffing is a type of attack which
involves listening in on information
transmitted over the internet
someone with ill intent could with the
help of a special device or software
listen to traffic and see in real time
what is coming into and leaving the
computer your passwords documents
photographs anything could end up in the
hands of another person
for some reason people believe that this
requires some special expensive
equipment but I'll show you how easy it
is to listen into traffic on the
internet and most importantly I'll tell
you how to protect yourself against it
this video was created by the some
subverification platform but more about
some sub in a bit
let's start with the theory
this is an RJ45 cable it's perhaps the
most common internet cable in the world
yes no Optics are the most widely used
but the good old twisted pair cabling
can still be found in almost every home
or office corridor so let's take a
closer look
inside our RJ45 we can see four cables
of differing colors each pair is made up
of two wires Twisted together
each wire has its own role green TX data
transmission orange RX data reception
blue DC plus allows positive flow of
power and data at a thousand megabits a
second Brown DC minus allows negative
flow of power and data at a thousand
megabits a second incoming and outgoing
Network traffic goes through a certain
pair of cores and the bytes themselves
are encoded by simply changing the
characteristics of the electrical signal
in them in order to understand the
principles of data interception in this
situation let's briefly explain how it
passes through the wires an electric
pulse with a frequency of several
hundred megahertz Goes Through the Wire
100 250 megahertz 500 and even more
megahertz on several pairs of wires at
once
and why pairs and how can we determine
the signal strength after all there is
no level by itself the level is always
relative to something else
for example our measure of the water
level during a flood is as to whether
the water has flooded its banks each
signal level corresponds to its own
voltage between two Twisted wires the
voltage is low one to two volts like in
a conventional battery and when we want
to transmit data our network card begins
to slightly change the voltage in the
pair of cables then half a volt more
than less than making it positive the
negative and so on and so forth but all
this happens very very quickly millions
of times per second
on the receiving side the voltage change
is recorded by the same network card and
it restores the information we transmit
using a particular logic a lot like
Morse code
so now we know how information is
transmitted but how can it be
intercepted
once the signal is transmitted through
the wires by changing the electrical
characteristics or voltage we can
connect to these very same wires in a
similar way to a multimeter which
measures the voltage without
disconnecting from the internet the
hacker takes a piece of twisted pair
consisting of just two chords you can
make it by yourself buy it on Amazon or
in a local store or modify a patch cord
laying around at home let's do
everything as a real hacker would
we'll take it and cut a little piece now
we are only interested in the RX pair
the first and second course and yes we
are only interested in the RX pair our
reception wires because if we try to
transmit some data we could end up
accidentally breaking the connection for
a while and why would we want to do that
we should be invisible our task is to
listen on the other end we connect the
first and second wires with ordinary
crocodile Clips so we end up with a
cable like this
we'll check how this works on the test
bed that we put together especially for
this experiment so this is the victim's
computer let's imagine that it's sitting
in an apartment from which a twisted
pair comes out and this is the computer
where the victim's information is being
sent in real life instead of this
computer there'll be Network equipment a
switchboard for example we're only using
two computers for the sake of testbed in
order to make it clearer and we're
squeezing in just here classic man in
the middle the hacker cuts the outer
body of the wire slightly with a
stationary knife the cut is parallel to
wires so as to not accidentally cut them
it's not necessary to remove the
insulation directly from the wires
themselves it's enough to just slightly
squeeze the crocodile clips and they
will pinch the insulation at the points
of contact
the attacker presses on the clips until
the packets are displayed on the sniffer
of the network card where the reverse
end of our wire is connected
if a hacker wants to listen to outgoing
traffic he connects to the orange pair
and if incoming then to the green one
we'll do both to show the full extent of
danger of this kind of attack
so we're going to listen to the outgoing
traffic in this case the hacker is
connected using an Android phone
some external network cards can be
automatically recognized by Android so
no action is required from a hacker
except perhaps having root rights
[Music]
an attacker could lie in word for hours
until the victim enters a password at
the other end or downloads a document of
interest to him
and in order not to be stuck waiting
around phone in hand a hacker can take
any miniature single board computer for
example a Raspberry Pi stick the
prepared wire into it connect to power
bank run the sniffer and leave it like
that for a day
or he could connect to the computer
remotely and view the victim's traffic
while sitting in the car under the
window because almost all mini computers
have their own Wi-Fi
let's start with passwords it's
important to understand that a hacker
can only listen to unprotected traffic
almost all modern resources support SSL
and TLS https encryption I.E all data
will be transmitted in encrypted form
nevertheless there are still many old
protocols that transmits data openly and
are still popular for example FTP or
network drives they are most often used
in the corporate sphere
let's look at SMTP POP3 and IMAP mail
protocols for our experiment which
sometimes work without encryption a good
example is a corporate mail server to
which a user connects from home directly
without a VPN
let's say an attacker is spying on the
boss of some company
it connects the crocodile Clips to the
twisted pair and weights at some point
the boss decides to check his mail his
mail client authenticates this on the
mail server and the attacker sees the
credentials his username and password in
plain text as well as the address of the
mail server and this data is enough to
get access to his business
correspondence
most likely our hacker will write some
scripts to make a traffic dump
a traffic dump is all intercepted
Network packets stored in a special file
format this format pcap PCA PNG stores
information about the structure of the
packet which layers Protocols are
present in the packet the mac and IP
addresses of the sender and recipients
the timestamp as well as the transmitted
data itself
by writing a traffic dump an attacker
will be able to see the data itself in
addition to all meta information
protocols IP addresses Etc and pretty
easily too
since in the dump this data is presented
as it is the hacker will most likely
view the intercepted data in special
traffic analysis software like Wireshark
however if our goal is to do a quick
search for sensitive data like passwords
and files we can use specialized
programs for this and to automate all
actions namely configuring the network
adapter for listening mode saving a
traffic dump and pulling files and
credentials out of it at the same time
we use a special script
foreign
the script will not only save the
traffic to a file for further analysis
but also conveniently divides the phone
screen into three areas Each of which
displays some important information the
first third of the screen shows the
listens to half of the traffic using
and that's just half of the traffic
since we agreed at the very beginning
that the attack only works on traffic
going in One Direction either incoming
or outgoing and well it's the most
famous program among hackers and
Protectors of information that saves
Network packets to a file a hacker may
need them to study the intercepted data
in more detail the second third is the
news utility which extracts credentials
from the traffic and in a mere moment we
extracted the password hash
automatically sent by the computer at
the time of connection to the network
drive using simple crocodile Clips the
next utility is a well-known tool in
narrow hacker circles aimed at
extracting credentials passwords or
their hashes for the most popular
protocols even if the attacker
intercepts the password in the form of a
hash it's checksum he can restore the
original password using the Brute Force
technique of dictionary password
matching the last third of the screen is
which simply extracts files by
signatures regardless of the data
transfer protocol we are all used to
storing data in files and all files
usually have certain types PDF jpeg zip
Etc often specified by the extension
however it is not only by extension that
the file type can be identified almost
every file more often at the very
beginning has special sequences of bytes
or signatures by which programs identify
them thus an attacker can also identify
them in network traffic the TCP extract
program does just that it listens to
network traffic and after hearing one of
the familiar signatures it understands
what type of file it is and then saves
it you can configure this program to
save a certain type of file or set your
signatures for a particular type of file
and now let's swap the crocodile Clips
around now we don't hear the network
traffic that our victim the boss of some
large company is transmitting instead we
see that the network card accepts it we
see which files he downloads at some
point the boss decides to log on to the
NAS network attached storage to View
financial reports which only he and a
couple of Chief accountants have access
to and now the hacker does too
the moment the boss downloaded
confidential documents this data was
sent to his network card in open form
via the very wires on which the hacker
had placed a wiretap and now having set
a special TCP extract program on the
recorded traffic he extracts the
documents as they were and sees a lot of
secret and confidential information
including the company's income its
excessive spending on toilet paper and
one of the documents containing bank
details
unfortunately such wiretapping cannot be
detected in any way
since no additional hops Trace routes
appear between laptops now let's explain
why this is possible
let's open the command prompt it's
available in any modern operating system
for example on Windows we do start run
CMD for this now we wrote the command
tracity google.com and we begin to see
how slowly some lines begin to be
written these are intermediate network
devices Hobs that are located between
your computer and the Google server
and almost always there will be several
such hops between you and one or another
server on the Internet only if you are
not directly connected to some server
first it will be the equipment of your
home provider then the switches of those
countries through which your network
traffic goes Etc and the first top is
most likely the IP address of your home
router if you have one
so usually in traffic interception
attacks when a hacker gets in the middle
somewhere along the path of packets his
presence can be detected but not with
this attack
and now let's talk about the
vulnerabilities of physical sniffing and
what methods of protection to use
firstly the attack can be carried out
from a room where there is unhindered
access to the wires of a twisted pair
the corridor of an office building or
the most ordinary entrance the key word
is unhindered it is necessary to
eliminate or check the possibility of
physical access to the wires that lead
to your home or are located in your
company
most often a twisted pair is found on
the last mile directly near subscriber
devices
fortunately Optics will most likely be
used between houses and company offices
that is over long distances you can't
listen to an optical cable in this way
therefore there are whole houses
companies or even cities that you won't
be able to listen to using this method
secondly it's important to note that
this method of sniffing is Possible only
on a connection with a speed of 10 or
100 megabits a second when four cores
orange and green pairs are involved that
is a four core wire
with an 8 core wire data is transmitted
differently at a speed of a thousand
megabits a second however even if there
are all eight cores in The Wire network
cards often don't get along well with a
thousand megabits mode
for example if we go back to our testbed
where the length of the wire is only a
couple of meters and all eight cores are
available network cards continue to work
in a 100 megabits a second mode
vulnerable to wiretapping thus if an
attacker is faced with a twisted pair
with an active connection of 1000
megabits a second it becomes impossible
to listen to traffic with two crocodile
clips
however you should know that hackers
have a way to get around this limitation
just cut one of the additional pairs of
cores that are needed to provide a speed
of 1000 megabits a second blue or brown
and in a few seconds it will
automatically downgrade to 100 megabits
a second which means wiretapping will be
possible again
in addition these pairs are used to
transmit power via power over internet
or Poe
as for Poe it can either play into the
hands of an attacker or not on the other
hand sometimes Poe can use the
additional pairs of cores blue and brown
required for a thousand megabit
connection thereby leaving only the 10
and 100 megabit connections vulnerable
to wiretapping but on the other hand Poe
can work without interfering with the
1000 megabit Connection in this case the
attacker can only cut one of the
additional pairs of wires but the
transmitting device the victim of a
traffic listening attack risks being
left without electrical power and the
attack will be thwarted it is important
to understand that such an attack
although very dangerous it's still
considered a passive attack the criminal
just listens to traffic on the fly but
he can't do anything with it modify it
and he definitely can't take control of
your computer but thanks to the league
of confidential data that could occur as
a result of listening he can get access
to all your online activities that take
place unencrypted and get into your
computer at a later time
thankfully the danger of such passive
listening to traffic is greatly reduced
in the era of widespread use of SSL or
TLS today all modern protocols that is
almost everything that's an ordinary
internet user uses is quite well
protected from eavesdropping this is
exactly what SSL or TLS certificates are
used for
the aim of these protocols is to ensure
a secure transmission of data at the
same time a pair of keys is used for
authentication such as simple but
effective mechanism reliably protects
ordinary users from a variety of traffic
interception attacks and listening in on
an internet cable is far from the only
example of these attacks a much more
common example is public Wi-Fi where
anyone can listen to your traffic
because it flies in all directions
including into the hackers receiving
antenna but it is the ultimate
encryption of traffic to every site
modern mail server or cloud storage that
protects you and your data from
wiretapping nevertheless a number of
protocols still use open authentication
these are well-known network drives FTP
and HTTP basic authentication on a proxy
and much more
therefore it's worth paying attention to
the quality of cable Lane if we're
dealing with companies it is
unacceptable to place open wires in an
unmonitored place it would also be
useful to use boxes cable channels or
hidden cable Lane as for a home user
we'd advise you to use modern secure
surfaces and watch some sub to stay safe
in the online jungle
information security is the key to
Contracting hackers my name is Lucas
from sumsup and I'm here to tell you a
little bit about how we protect our
users data thumbs up is an all-in-one
verification platform that secures every
step of the customer's Journey
besides being compliant we ensure that
our product is a proven market leader
and that's why we often conduct
independent penetration tests to
identify potential weaknesses like weak
authentification or insufficient error
handling sensitive information leakage
and other problems with our solution
your company passwords will be encrypted
with two-factor authentication by
default among other security measures to
eliminate any loopholes for hackers the
product is equipped with an automatic
anomaly detection tool that tracks
suspicious activities such as logins
from different regions repeat password
guesses if you want to start living in a
world free of hackers well check out our
product by clicking on the link below to
find